متابعه الثورات الميدانيه معانا من خرسون
مراسل الجزيره تامر الصمادي
سلام خضر
العمليات المكثفه في اكثر من منطقه في خير
سنتابع اخر تطوراتها مع كتابه
القصف يوم امس واليوم كان الاعنف على
الاطلاق منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا وفقا لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
للسرطان الاوكرانيه ايضا اكثر من 160
صاروخا
استهدف مناطق عده مقاطعه عده في الجنوب
والشرق وفقا لقوات الاوكرانيه هيئه
الاركان قالت بانه تم اسقاط الكثير من تلك
الصواريخ الروسيه التي انطلقت من بحر
قزوين ومن البحر الاسود لكن في الحقيقه
هنا في خير شون القصه لا يهدا القصف
متواصل القصف الروسي على قلب المدينه وعلى
العديد من القرى والبلدات الواقعه على طول
خطا التماس بالاضافه الى القصف المدفعي
المكثف والثقيل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه ونحن نستمع الى هذه الاصوات منذ
الصباح استطيع القول بان القصف على اشد
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه تحديدا
على ضفتين نهر هنالك ايضا تقول السلطات
اوكرانيه بانها انسحبت او رصدت انسحابات
لبعض الوحدات من القوات الروسيه تحديدا من
منطقه نوفا كخوفكا وكخوفك ايضا وتقول بان
بانه مع نهايه العام سوف يكون هنالك مزيد
من الانسحابات لوحدات القوات الروسيه على
وقع القصف الاوكراني المكثف على تلك
المناطق لكنها في المقابل ايضا تتحدث عن
قيام القوات الروسيه ببناء مزيد من
التحصينات في الخطوط الخلفيه ما وراء
النهر حيث تتمركز القوات الروسيه هناك هذا
فيما يخص خير سون التي تحدث او تحدثت
القياده العسكريه والاقليميه فيها يوم امس
عن مقتل اربعه واصابه عدد اخر من المدنيين
نتيجه القصه الوضع الانساني في المدينه
غايه في الماساويه الخدمات مقطوعه بالكامل
تحديدا خدمه الكهرباء الماء همم الوسائل
التدفئه وذلك منذ ايام ومع ذلك وعلى وقع
هذا القصد تواصل السلطات الاخرانيه والم
هي تحديدا في المدينه
مناشادتها للسكان بضروره النزوح همم وهذه
المناشده ليست جديده هي مناشده متواصله
منذ اكثر من اسبوعين عندما سيطرت القوات
الاوكرانيه او استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه
المدينه مدينه خيرسون مره اخرى من قبل
القوات الروسيه في ميكولايب ايضا القصف
متواصل من كليف القريبه من خيرسون القصف
متواصل على البنيه التحتيه وفقا لقياده
عمليات الجنوب تحديدا على المناطق
الساحليه اوديسا ايضا القريبه والواقعه
على البحر الاسود صباح هذا اليوم اعلنت
السلطات الاوكرانيه عن اسقاط دفاعاتها
صاروخين انطلاقا من شبه جزيره القرد وقالت
بان همم ما تم اسقاطه امس واليوم ايضا كان
يستهدف بشكل كبير البنيه التحتيه الكهرباء
مقطوعه الى حد كبير عن مدينه اديسا التي
كانت تعتبر من اهم المدن الاوكرانيه من
ناحيه السياحه وجذب السياحه اليوم المدينه
تغرق في الظلام والتطور ايضا في ديني برو
في التي تعرضت ايضا للقصف المتواصل من قبل
القوات الروسيه وفقا للجانب الاوكراني يوم
امس نهايه السي فيما يخص الشرق المواجهات
على اشدها تحديدا عند محور باخ موت تقول
السلطات ان اكثر من 25 قريه وبلده استهدفت
من قبل القوات الروسيه طيله الساعات
الماضيه لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها
لازالت تسيطر على المدينه
على دنيتك ماذا في التفاصيل
صحيح قال سي صباح اليوم بعيده السابعه
تقريبا اكثر من 10 صواريخ سقطت على احياء
عده داخل مدينه دونيتك ووسط هذه المدينه
الاستهداف الصباحي ادى بحسب السلطات
المحليه الى احداثي اضرار في منازل سكنيه
وفي منشاه واحده على الاقل للبنيه التحتيه
طبعا دنيا
السلطات بانه الاعنف منذ عام 2014 طوال
الاسابيع الثلاثه الماضيه المدينه تستهدف
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه بشكل شبه يومي
ما يؤدي الى سقوط قتلى وجرحى وايضا اضرار
على صعيد المنشات الحيويه والمنازل
السكنيه وايضا بعض المرافق العامه الجامعه
جامعه مدينه دانيست استوديفت اكثر من مره
كتدرائيه المدينه الاكبر قصفت لنحو اربع
مرات خلال الايام الماضيه وايضا احد
الفنادق في المدينه تعرض لقصف
ده فين اوكرانيه
هدفيدونيتس في لوغانس في الوضع لا يقل
سوءا ال سي السلطات هناك تتحدث عن
استهدافات المستمره من قبل قوات
الاوكرانيه لمنازل سكنيه بصواريخ هاي مارس
ما يؤدي ايضا الى سقوط قتلى وجرحى اشير
الى مساله اخيره ال سي الى ان رئيس
الموالي لروسيا تحدث صباح اليوم في حديث
صحفي عن ما يجري في مدينه
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه في مدينه
باخمت لا يزالوا مستمرا وتحدث الرجل عن ان
القوات دنيتك بالتعاون مع قوات
تقريبا تحكم الطوق على مدينه بخمط وتحاصر
القوات الاوكرانيه داخل المدينه قال ان
القتال لا يزال همم يسير عند اطراف
المدينه لكنه توقع ان تتمكن القوات
المواليه لروسيا من احكام الطوق على مدينه
باخبط قريبا بحسب ما قال وتحدث ايضا عن ان
وات لاوكرانيه تستمر برفض مدينه باخموت
بمزيد من التعزيزات تحديدا من منطقه
خيرسون يقول لبوتشيلن ان القوات
الاوكرانيات تسحب بعض الوحدات المتواجده
في خرسان وتتجه بها الى مدينه مخموت وقال
ايضا ان القوات الاوكرانيه همم
تتكبد خسائر كبيره على صعيد الجنود تحديدا
شكرا جزيلا لك من دونيتك سلام خضر وشكرا
لتامر صمادي حدثنا